visit mercury and you'll be visiting the
only other planet in the inner solar
system
with a magnetic field but it's very
existence defies explanation now the
mystery there is that in order to have a
magnetic field you need to have a
interior to the planet that is at least
partially molten mercury one of the
smallest of the planets would have been
expected to really a frozen all the way
through and yet we have a relatively
strong very well-defined magnetic field
that appears to have a source that's
located deep in the planet whatever
mechanism is driving Mercury's magnetic
field it's too weak to protect it from
the full force of the Sun the solar wind
buffets Mercury's thin atmosphere and in
the process it puts on a light show
reason you'd want to go to mercury as a
travel destination would be this snide
side view because it's gonna be highly
unique in the solar system
you have sodium that's atoms that are
streaming off and giving off this yellow
light so you could almost look as like
you're standing in a doughnut of of
sodium emission with the Sun rise three
months away you'll have plenty of time
to sit back and take in the view framed
in a halo of amber light
in some sense you could get a very nice
light show and I know people go to
Canada to look at the Northern Lights
all the time and so that would be a
reason to go to mercury not a night owl
then head into the light but when you're
this close to a stellar rotisserie make
sure you pack plenty of sunscreen
if you want a suntan you can't beat the
dusty sands of mercury stretch out on
the ground here and the Sun crackles and
fizzes right above you appearing almost
three times bigger in the sky and seven
times as hot if you were walking on the
surface of mercury you'd need one heck
of a spacesuit because if you were in
the Sun it would be extremely hot you
would see an enormous Sun in the sky
that would just you know burn you to
death if you you know spend any time in
it whatsoever the mercury really climbs
on mercury - a toast the 840 degrees
Fahrenheit
that's about twice as hot as your
kitchen oven on full heat you'll need a
bit more than SPF 30 sunscreen here